Now the halting problem isn't the undecidable problem.
There's actually a very large number of undecidable problems as we'll soon see.
And the technique here is almost the same that we use for showing np-completeness.
So if you remember that once we had shown SAT to be np-complete.
We could take a whole bunch of other problems such as vertex cover, clique, and independent set
and of course many more and show these to be np-complete using a reduction
because we were able to show that if you could solve vertex cover in polynomial time
then you could also solve SAT in polynomial time and we'll now use a very similar technique.
Now we know the halting problem is undecidable, we can look at other problems
and show through a kind of reduction that if we could solve these problems here
then we would be able to solve the halting problem, which of course is not possible.
Now, the first problem we might be looking at is a generalized version of the halting problem.
As you remember, the halting problem takes as input a program
and an input on which to run that program and what we could now ask
is of course a more general question and that is, does the program have any input
on which it stops or does it always go into an infinite loop?
And we'll call that the generalized halting problem.
So we're given P and now the question is, is there any input I for which P halts?
And I'll show you now that this problem here is also undecidable
and then we'll look at other problems and you can show that they are undecidable.
So the proof always work in a very similar fashion. You again start out with an assumption.
And then lead that assumption into a contradiction.
The initial assumption is that we had an algorithm or a program
that can decide the generalized halting problem.
So assume there's a program P' that solves this problem here.
Now, how could we use this program here to solve the halting problem?
Well, that's actually quite easy. So we have the program and the input.
And now we construct a new program from that. That problem is actually quite easy.
We just make the input here part of the program code so in kind of a pseudocode writing here
the first line of that program P'' would be set the input variables to I
and that is now part of the program code of this program here.
Here it was a separate input and now it's part of the program code.
So we set the input variables to the input and then run P as always.
And now it's clear that if we have a problem that solves the generalized halting problem
then we can just feed it to this program here because this program here
actually ignores any input that we give to it.
Finding out if that program over here will ever terminate is the same as asking
if the original program P will terminate on the input I.
This program here cannot exist because if the generalized halting problem were decidable
this would also mean that the special halting problem here
where we are given an explicit input would also be decidable.
So we know that this problem is now undecidable as well.